the sun's atmosphere known as the corona
is millions of degrees hotter than its
surface scientists think the heat is
caused by magnetic turbulence but
they've struggled to get a
high-resolution picture of what's going
on a new telescope on board this
sounding rocket gets a better view as
the rocket falls to earth scientists had
just 5 minutes to take images of the Sun
it was just long enough to make a
high-res movie let's take a look at what
they see zooming in on this particularly
active region
left we've got the grainy old image from
a satellite on the right you can see the
one from the new telescope scientists
say they can see a hot spot where
magnetic lines come together
they also capture images of another part
of this violent patch on the bottom you
can see a braid of hot gas slowly
unwinding it's hard to make out but
there's a lot of hot material streaming
out to the upper left that braid by the
way is the size of the earth these newly
seen phenomena might explain the corona
super hot temperatures researchers are
now hoping to put their camera on a
satellite to get a longer look
you